participent à cette opération pour
pour au moins ne pas avoir autant de
peps
puisqu'on en a beaucoup de pères en fils
au film parce que c'est la saison la
coopérative on a eu fatou brasser et je
sollicite je suis sollicité bon monsieur
colère pour donner un coup de bain et
qu'on puisse vendre le peu qu'on peut
vendre quoi c'est très intéressant pour
que le martiniquais puisse réaliser
qu'ils ont des producteurs qui
travaillent qu'on peut donner à notre
peut pas manger et évacue notre
marchandise et que le bruit qu'on puisse
être autonome sur le prix quoi assez
bien voir reproduire
il faut compter six mois et en est un
cyclone il faut mettre deux en un an ou
deux ans ou à partir pratiquement tous
les ans nous vivons ce problème là on
est dans la période
si on a un mauvais temps cette année
2020 ses coups les aristos film très peu
il faudra attendre 2020 si on n'a pas de
sens
je suis pratiquement nez dedans répondre
à la question je suis né dedans j'ai
fait quand même là l'ébénisterie
quinze jeunes g
je suis bien dedans j'aime la culture
l'amour de la terre et puis j'ai compris
quelque chose
l'agriculteur donations peuvent à manger
on a ici pire il y à l'appui à tous mais
on donne on peut pas manger est en
contact de tout le monde et est vive
dans le milieu agricole quoi en prêchant